I lied right to Bill Polian face he said
have you ever held before I said
absolutely what happened the rest of
your hoody it's arm firm though there's
no sleeves alone somebody is trying to
chainsaw down our mailbox that's it
we're a quarter the way through the
season we nose winning the Super Bowl
Simms yep we can't cheat 100%
look every year one team starts off
really great another team doesn't and
it's kind of become the first four weeks
or like the extended precede yes and
you've been telling me for the last few
days it's for players too yeah without a
doubt I mean it's the new age of the NFL
we know with all the new rules that
players and the NFL has the coaching the
collective bargaining agreement the
amount of hours and practices you can do
in training camp in OTAs that's hampered
game plans but I think the other thing
that we're seeing especially this year
we didn't see a lot of the stars a whole
lot through the preseason we saw that
this preseason where guys like Ezekiel
Elliott didn't play oh you know what
week three and four all of a sudden he
starts to go off Jadeveon Clowney I know
he was dealing with some injuries but
nobody wants to risk it don't play
preseason right now all the sudden he
plays the Indianapolis Colts last Sunday
and we see the Beast of clowny Unleashed
fumble recovery exactly right so I think
this is something that we have to look
at going for it Alvin Kamara I know he's
had some moments yeah through the first
three weeks but last week against the
Giants he was a different guy exploding
through the hole so I do think the early
part of the season with the new rules
and coaches not wanting their stars to
get hurt yeah the star players are not
really getting into their prime form
until week three four or five Earl
Thomas didn't play that much
unfortunately he's not playing again the
rest of this season and he showed the
Seattle sideline how he really feels
with this the state bird of New Jersey
yes a middle finger probably right in
the direction of Pete Carroll and we
wondered what other NFL players would
love to give people the bird
[Music]
I'm gonna let you go first okay young
guy been taking a lot of grief right oh
ha Mitchell too risky yeah he's given
the middle finger you know who he's
giving it to the Bears fans first of all
oh we don't know he's matured you frisky
good is he elite he's giving it to his
own coach Matt Negi going oh I don't
have the full scope of the old offense
hey take this six touchdowns everybody
back the eff off I'm going quarterback
as well and it's yeah fitzpatrick and
he's flipping this bird squarely at dirt
cutters dome dirt cutter comes out to
the game and says I should be fired
you know what Fitzpatrick agrees your
defense allows 35 points in the first
half let's bench the quarterback that's
the issue all right where you going oh
good old Jersey Joe Flacco he knows how
to give the middle finger he's saying up
yours Baltimore in all football fans you
can keep Lamar Jackson on the bench he
can come in and run a few gadget plays
every now and then were three and one
and we might be in the Super Bowl man I
like it he's given it to him right now I
feel like this is too similar people
yeah this is to everyone that likes to
talk about the impending doom of Andy
Dalton I can't win the playoffs no he
could never get by all right well under
bill laser he's been a revelation he's
connecting with AJ green he's connecting
with Tyler boy he doesn't even have Joe
Mixon
he's doing this with Giovanni Bernard
he's looked great and he Dalton to the
haters it and a finger and then another
finger okay
give me another one how about a fake one
and Odell Beckham triple Birds say quads
going you like can you stopped over to
the ball one yard behind the line of
scrimmage and then I have to play
dodgeball and make everybody on the
defense miss I'm getting killed out here
and Odell Beckham jr. is going can you
just stand there in the pocket I'm open
downfield there's some one-on-one shots
I didn't think even Pat Shermer he's
going can you please teach the old line
to block better so we can throw the ball
down the field man they're they're
flicking off everybody three I got one
more for you one more Super Bowl
Blake bortles this was a middle finger
Blake this is yeah this was a q Chris
since week he should just get si MMS on
his middle finger like that when he has
a good week he can just put it right up
there and tell me to shut up
you and bortles yeah not best football
friends no us big-time best football
friends and we took our act on the road
to take on the 49ers the 909 you
finished that my friend 49ers thank you
you may our together but we feel like we
got you yeah I think so girls don't
think that nice though it's really weird
how did you guys meet we worked out
every single day together and then
somehow got drafted the same team in the
same round like 15 picks are part for
each other as soon as I got drafted
instantly George on the FaceTime just
that's a cute little love story God nice
little warm-up for you guys that's so
cute I am I hope they get harder than
that
yay oh gosh baby what did you run for 5
- Wow
and Trent what does you have I ran a
forever oh no don't cheat I'm so bad at
this damn it
it's embarrassing it is embarrassing
nurse I know you know my that's why I'm
even more embarrassed these are the
moments when you question your
friendship it seems like it's around
here what do you guess so far away
because you just get you like you would
know of my birthday he's like a december
guy i just it seemed like a december
guys you seem like a former beard
damn what happened to the rest to your
hoodie it's arm firm buggers no sleeves
allowed far oh I tweeted that stop y'all
are giving me good hints right now so
I'm gonna go for something like this I
want candy bumper dumper dude that
wasn't it wasn't judge see I remember
things about you did I'm not like my
birth I'm embarrassed about the very I
expect to present rice beans peppers
sometimes hot sauce multiple scoops of
Bryson that's crazy but you go a double
orange chicken I was honestly he's gonna
fire everybody want a shrimp honey
sesame I'll switch it up how much money
do you spend at Panda Express I like
Chinese food a lot yeah I feel like our
connection is definitely better than
theirs at this point
oh you don't work more fluid there's
this forest oh yeah I play quarterback
Omaha blue goat paint man thank you Oh
greatest quarterback of all time Aaron
Rodgers oh my Chuck um we want him in
the Hall of Fame he's close to me he's
oh so sit right over drafted by the
Dallas Cowboys white lie about Oh lady
band Arash go bad old coach Bob
take it in I was awesome quarterback for
the 49ers jaimegirl our best friend on
the team lived without /jp flame so
every policy boss yeah these are a lot
easier just know the album everybody
listens to them your feelings challenges
so you put my stapler in jello no no no
yeah I can't believe we're tied right
now okay Wow we can do this
I got it okay I'm a big bass here can
you say do it you say okay big bass here
stop cheating at rent
yeah just like you're going to the
second level that's not the let's get
all the ones in the bass
okay where are you I don't know what
you're doing seems like it upon yourself
to do what you want to trust me
yeah you think your bass okay what do
you want to connect it over there oh
holy crap Lepke I mean other one hear me
another one
yes it's fine give it a swing
[Music]
sup guys let's go we still have look at
that strong strong baby let's go that's
alright I shoulda known your birthday
soon so we took our first L kid ol and
Trent Taylor he's decided to go like
Deva wide receiver at the end and build
your own spaghetti you didn't listen no
teamwork he has no idea we're talking
well it's alright I want him to be our
third best football I think it was a
cute you guys both wear Jordans together
it's really cool Oh Jordan kiss huh I'm
wearing the greatest basketball player
of all time
LeBron James thank you I'm also on that
well let's talk about another goat
one that set the new record this weekend
Adam Vinatieri the best most field goals
made of all time which is a crit like
Morten Andersen Gary Andersen I never
thought those guys could ever be caught
like I thought they were cyborgs you
held for this guy but like everything I
see about you pat is you have a great
time you can party you can hold it down
and everything I see a Vinatieri is like
you know he's very buttoned up yeah I
couldn't imagine you guys getting Loosli
I can't imagine it either actually we
were a very yin and yang right situation
first of all when Bill Polian drafted me
I lied right to Bill Polian face he said
have you ever held before I said
absolutely I kicked and punted in
college I said absolutely bill I hold
all the time in practice I knew that was
gonna happen they draft me as a punter
to hold for the greatest kicker of all
time yeah Venna terry calls me to
congratulate me he knew that I kicked in
college so he said have you ever held
before and I said absolutely not a slide
right the bullying's face I'm so sorry
so he flew me to Ken Walter who was his
holder in New England in North Carolina
for like a weekend for like a holding
like boot camp Wow laces out oh it's a
whole operation because if you're off by
that much if you've missed if I miss a
finitary misses a kick right and I'm the
rookie idiot punter it's a hundred
percent of my fault yeah no one's away
without ya so we had a rough start but
we became very close friends he's a
great human being I can feel the respect
you have for him I own as well
long time I mean it's seven years of
ball holding for the guy and he was just
so damn good
talk about nerds and your luck oh my god
another guy that I think I feel like you
and him are diametrically opposite
humans he's so much smarter than me I
would assume a lot of people but me in
particular yeah like SAT words he's just
using things in his just stream of
consciousness yes is way over my head
does he ever cut loose I think he had
some craft beers every once in a while I
think he's a craft beer guy well yeah it
makes me fun I like the chugga-boom
beers what about Jim Irsay though that's
raw manna the man you have you hey Quinn
this is the first thing I want to know
okay the owners box with the
Indianapolis Colts has a special glass
in case because he's burning fish so he
can smoke cigs in the stadium and watch
the game and it's probably the only one
I don't know how it's legal but I guess
when you own the team you can do
whatever you want just built a glass box
to smoke cigarettes oh yeah I know poke
his head out every once in a while
whenever there was a special guest
they'll give the wave to the jumbotron
place will go crazy back into the glass
okay he's an owner that does live and
die with the team I've heard the stories
of whenever I shank a punt that there's
like a god damnit McAfee who can't in
the glass tanks right so he is the guy
that lives and dies with his team that's
all so whenever I retired I had a great
conversation with that man though I have
a lot of respect and appreciation for
Jim Irsay
sounds like it was a hell of a
conversation well he I mean we took me
on a trip you know he's like you know
they say the people that are positive
they see the glass is half-full and the
people that are negative they see the
glass is half-empty I've always said get
a smaller glass the son of a bitch's
food I saw yeah it was a there was
ninety minutes of just magic with the
guy what did you get on your Wunderlich
score pretty good action Dale I'm really
good holy crap like 24 yeah I've been
able to tell that the show comm
pre-order Pat McAfee professional
baseball player where I never played
baseball day in my life right I played
professionally in a minor league game we
recorded the whole thing through your
professional professional baseball B
yeah well every other person needs to
see the games we don't it is June 26 and
we're
our week 5 predictions right now the
Philadelphia Eagles are for no Carson
Wentz has played all four games
I think the Jaguars are in trouble one
in three start they want to bench their
quarterback Blake bortles but they're
the only team that has other
quarterbacks that throw the ball worse
than Blake bortles so they can't even
benches a Jaguar start one every way
June 26 is that the date yes it is
you are a Cowboys fan what is your
record after four weeks oh he gave one
okay what is your bold prediction on
June 26th it's magically the Bucks what
are you smoking what is the record of
the Kansas City Chiefs the starting
quarterback what are they doing right
now I think he's right say qualms
Barkley leading all-purpose yards
offensive player in the NFL leading
Rookie of the Year talks Sam Bradford
gets hurt the Rosewood one Josh Rosen
comes in leads Arizona little winning
streak not a talk a lot of buzz big fine
jets record line one why did you become
a Jets fan why not a Johnson I'm from
Jersey right blowing up had season
tickets had always been fans so I lose
like hereditary okay do you like those
Sims no no I don't like him either that
whole family's kind of weird
my name is Chris Sims nice to meet you
Cory how you like that
my dad's Ultra weird so that's Jude 26
we kept the paper Sims we did that kids
the papers for and oh yes he knew it
he's the new Oracle Oracle I will anoint
that kid the new Oracle for that you
have been anointed that woman though did
not recognize you
I assume that everyone recognizes a 6-5
blonde guy that looks like Phil Simms I
think everyone thinks your Sims
apparently not sometimes people think
I'm boomer sighs this kid you never know
but the being the Sims is it what's it
like it's a great thing there was some
weird and some bad I mean first of all I
could wake up on a given day of dad
threw three interceptions in game I'd
say Sims sucks on this publication
that's coming that's not always easy to
see your father being portrayed that way
story that sticks out to me
Giants beat the Denver Broncos on the
road 1989 I'm going to bed later that
night okay it's about 11 o'clock going
to bed a little late for a nine-year-old
deal with it okay and we hear a I think
a revving engine in our driveway we're
like there's somebody in our driveway
revving their car engine we look out the
window my mother and I and somebody is
trying to chainsaw down our mailbox to
keep it as phil simms memento i guess i
guess he was impressed with the way big
Phil played that Wow
question yes how sweet was this mailbox
my mama picked one that would literally
the wood pillar was like this big the
guy only got like a quarter of the way
through before the cops got there and he
got all because Phil beat Elway and the
Broncos happy about it the guy lived in
our town
that's the weirdest part about it when I
say hi hey weird guy from my old town
how you doing hey guys I'm Marty
Dumbledore and you're watching a magical
show series and left Co the Guardian
levity Oso
life after Ally is hard IRA one up one
down I'm sorry the Rams are just too
good
move it on somebody and left go another
two hundred and fifty dollars a new
somebody's same left go this time we're
going to Central Park
if you're ever near Central Park and you
don't know where to go this is the guy
to talk to Steve super Steve this is the
staple Superman shirt every day is a
good day every day every day is a good
day alright so here's what we're doing
I've explained to you Thursday Night
Football I'm going around New York I
need two random pick people to pick the
games Patriots are hosting the Colts
they're ten and a half point favorites I
want you to take me through what you
think when you hear that Patriots are
home they have they have the edge I'm
gonna have to go at the Patriots ride in
that hot hand to keep it going are you
worried about Andrew Luck at all and in
general I don't I don't spend much time
thinking about Andrew Luck or worry
about them in any sense but Thursday
maybe maybe all right if you win we're
gonna come back money in an envelope I
don't want to shake it around out here I
don't know what Gavin is going to drop
so I wish you luck sir
thank you hey Bishop any cab next week
sounds good so a man super steve is
going Patriots minus ten and a half oh I
don't know Scuba Steve but I'm gonna
ride with them it's you are I am I ride
with the what I mean New England the way
they looked last week it's Thursday
night they're at home I don't know Colts
coming off a five quarter football game
yes I'm going with scuba Steve it's
super Steve scuba see he has a oneness
about him right that I think he's gonna
be our spiritual guide into betting
success okay that's good for scuba Steve
one thing that we're very excited about
you're very rude is the Jaguars defense
holy crap oh my gosh trying to contain
Patrick Mahoney
oh man crush again this Sunday game for
us is football porn oh it is it is so
good that we want you to join in if
you're watching that game anytime you
see something crazy hit us with the
hashtag football porn oh baby or if
there's something happened in your game
that's great great highlights big hits
big touchdowns and you get excited
football porn oh my gosh completions
bombs big plays hard hits it's awesome
it's like football porn oh good job yeah
but this game for real though I mean I'm
excited as any game I've seen are you
more confident in mahomes having success
or the Jaguars messing with mahoma is
more likely in your mind
the Jaguars messing with mahomes Wow yes
it's still young and this Jaguars
defense as you and I have talked about
many times it's the one of the most
talented defenses in the history of
football they much more talented than
Denver Oh much more talented they play
two or three defenses in Jacksonville
and say screw you you know what we're
playing try to beat us in all
seriousness it might be the game of the
year I'm so excite our super I mean
seriously have a man crush on so many
guys out here for Sims peace out homies
holla holla holla we will see you next
week and enjoy the games we even got one
of those things over dude next level Wow
butcher report is the truth oh that is
one of those things that's so minor but
it I feels like a really unbelievable 45
camera op reports bleacher report is
clocking rushing hey what's up homies
thanks for watching subscribe to the B
our YouTube channel man you're such a
millennial also while you're here we
have a lot of other videos check them
out and then what time does our show
come out Wednesday 8:00 p.m. be there or
be square
he ruined it it was really close